are you into planned construction
complex sewage systems and of course
proper fiscal management well a lot of
you seem to be as symfony inspired city
skylines is heading major sales numbers
develop I finished studio colossal order
the game is now sold more than 500,000
copies impressive seeing's are only
released on March 10th it moved 250,000
copies in its first 24 hours making it
publisher Paradox Interactive fastest
selling game yet
on Monday however the company said the
single player game has now doubled that
figure looks like we broke the 500k
barrier it wrote on Twitter huge thanks
to every single chirpy who supported us
so far less than three ah in game sports
8 out of 10 cities skylines review
real-life mayor Brett Todd wrote right
now there is no better way to take a
peek at life as a mayor without filing
your papers to run for office in the
real world I mean he'd know right look
he's got the chain and everything city
skyline also offers mod support via the
Steam Workshop allowing for such
building necessities as elevated
pedestrian round emotes Soviets hospital
and of course everyone's favorite large
agricultural field finally but it's not
just your average gamer giving this
morning lark ago a former Maxis employee
he worked on 2013's SimCity and was out
of a job after Maxis Emeryville shutdown
has launched a patreon seeking funding
to create buildings for paradox his game
for more information about brian Shannon
and his crowdfunding campaign just check
out his patreon at the link on screen so
have you been playing City skylines
how'd you feel about these sales figures
on are you excited about in the morning
potential personally I'm looking forward
to city's Skyrim let me know in the
comments down below and for all the rest
year of video game news come on back to
GameSpot
you